m
dans le cadre de la journée de la
protection contre les animaux maltraités
des collégiens du conseil départemental
des jeunes se sont rendus à la spa de
saintes maries pour aider les bénévoles
et faire un don de nourriture pour les
animaux placier une action importante
pour la présidente qui souhaiteraient
que les animaux soient traités comme des
personnes à part entière pourtant ces
animaux et qui ne doivent pas être
traités comme des objets comme des êtres
humains on apprend les êtres vivants de
pratiquer comme les objets hurle apprend
à l'école navale de douala et aussi
parce qu'avoir un animal domestique
c'est si vous savez qu ils trouvent que
les personnes qui passent comme en
adopte un animal dans son équipe et ne
soyez pas ce que c'est comme un membre
de la famille pour les plus jeunes y
aura un chat ou un chien qui ne s'offre
pas justement de deux mètres par un
animal de son avis les membres du
conseil départemental des jeunes
prennent à coeur cette action visant à
protéger les animaux et souhaite
proposer des solutions pour stopper la
maltraitance et l'abandon bien trop
présent à la réunion
moi ça va prendre beaucoup de plaisir ce
que je vois des animaux qui sont petit
puisque à la mediapad animaux du tout et
ben moi aussi je voudrais sensibiliser
les gens pour dire qu'il faut pas
maltraiter les animaux
puisque les animaux sont comme des gens
et ben saumâtre est un animal comme se
nomme maltraite quelqu'un janvier a
demandé ils veulent que l'amour une
après-midi de bonheur pour ces jeunes
qui ont pu câliner chiens et chats
quelques heures de plaisir qui n'ont pas
suffi pour repartir les mains vides
aujourd'hui on a commencé par une visite
un petit peu guidée de la partie pour
les chiens et ensuite on appelait
balader et on si je suis venu demander
les chats et chatons et j'ai craqué sur
route trois charges dont malheureusement
deux ont été réservées et donc qu'il
reste là petit chaton cris j'espère
pouvoir le prendre et je veux parce que
quand même s'il serait bien de montfort
une nouvelle chanson ma famille parce
que c'est vrai qu'à être ici c'est bien
les êtres en passant de la famille ont
pu étonner d'un mot si ces suspects un
peu mieux oui on va dire le ridicule
j'ai craqué sur un petit chien et j'ai
appelé mes parents ils ont dit oui donc
voilà vraiment vraiment très près et
vraiment très très content le conseil
départemental des jeunes s'étaient déjà
rendus à la spa de sainte marie et de
saint pierre en 2013 pour une action
similaire